cameras lenses yeah do those how much do
those matter you mentioned director of
photography what what's your
how much do you love
the the feel
the smell of equipment that does the
visual filming you know there's some
people they're just like
they they they love lenses
how much do you love that and or versus
how much do you focus on the story or
access and all this kind of stuff i'm
not a tech geek
um but because
during
the bulk of my career i um
i've worked as a director of photography
myself for other people
in order to pay the bills over the years
um you know i know the technical side of
it because i i've had to know it and
i've had to train myself and learn it so
i see them as necessary tools
and
again because i believe
you know film and cinema ish is and
should be visually driven and not
verbally driven um i want the best tools
possible
within my means right and within the the
logistical
ability of the project because we have
to go so small right i can't
i can't afford nor can i bring a huge
hundred thousand dollar lens so if i
give you a trillion dollars a trillion
dollars yeah wow
unlimited yes there's still huge
constraints that have nothing to do with
money yeah like you just said yeah
so what
what cameras would you use you know what
i do with the trillion dollars
i could do a lot of things
you're only allowed to fund the film and
no corrupt stuff where you like
use the film to actually help children
no you're not allowed to do any of that
what i would do with the children is i
wouldn't invest in a well i guess i
would invest in crime i would i would
increase capacity
to do more films what i would do so i
would buy basically the perfect little
you know
mini equipment set right but then i
would train
three teams maybe to do the same thing
that i've been doing so we could
multiply and scale up more and more
stories yeah that's what i would do with
the mind but the actual setup would
remain small
and nimble yeah
and uh what about
lighting do you usually use natural
light do you ever do
um i mean sorry for the technical
questions here but
um
highlighting the drama of the human face
yeah uh
that's the visual that's art that's yeah
like to to reveal reality yeah
uh
at its deepest is art and uh do you use
lighting no lighting is such a big part
of that you use do you ever do
artificial lighting do you try to do
natural always you know the best
lighting instrument in the world is the
sun
at the right moment of the day
and so i predominantly use natural light
um at certain moments
and just shape natural light
during the course of these small human
rights stocks that's not to say we don't
bring instruments sometimes but when we
do
they're very small and again
compact so
for example i have this small little
tube kit that's just three instruments
right that you can charge with the usb
because electricity is often a major
issue where we go so there's just three
little tube lights with magnetic backs
that if we find in a situation where you
know we can't get enough exposure for a
hallway or something and we have the
time to throw it up we'll throw it up if
people are walking if if collaborators
are walking down that hallway a lot for
example at night just so we can see them
right so it's instances like that or
if we do do an interview which
we don't do very often but if we do just
so we have a key light on the face right
and always bring a reflector or two you
know just to shape natural light as well
in ways but it's um
it's about shaping rather than producing
light for us
got it as we sit surrounded by black
curtains in complete natural life
so just just so you know this room
uh
is is like a violation of the basic
principles of
of using the sun so behind the large
curtains
are giant windows yeah so this whole
should i rip them
[Laughter]
you